welcome back to Baba knows best the only
game show where real Brown dads compete
for cold hard cash we're down to our
final three dads let's meet them up
first
an aerospace engineer from Seattle
Washington give it up for Mohammed now
Mohammed I hear one of your hobbies is
reading the newspaper I love loose paper
okay our next Baba is from Fremont
California he's a mechanical engineer
ladies and gentlemen give it up for
Akbar a far
I hear you were recently kicked out of a
Costco for trying too many samples I go
in and they said no sir you cannot keep
eating your tortilla chip with salsa I
said god damn it I paint I will need as
much sunshine cheap as I need to do our
last Baba's from Baltimore Maryland
he's a structural engineer ladies and
gentlemen its Nasser Nasser I hear that
you like to mow your lawn in your
speedos what do you mean on the forum
yeah that one of the activities you like
to do is right mowing the lawn or lewin
land in your speedo inside a speedo what
am I going to do wear my underwear all
right let's play our next game what's
the matter with you
all right you guys know the rules every
justified direct hit on a target is five
points hit the wrong target you lose
five points your money shoe is worth
triple points you guys ready yes yeah
let's go dad I got a C whoa whoa
five points across the board I got into
UCLA I'm gonna kill this bitch I'm gonna
burn this house down I had some bacon
oh now up bird you hit the arsonist
but your son did have bacon so he's
gonna burn in hell forever my hands are
sweaty minus five points we're forming a
band
Oh shoes down times up now Nasser you
did hit the kid with the frosted tips
but you used your own shoe so no points
there chat now that was a great round
let's check in on our podiums to see
who's in the lead all right Mohammed is
in the lead but it's still anyone's game
so let's move on to our final challenge
like a rock will play out real-life
events from your life and whoever
doesn't cry wins the challenge and the
game you guys ready let's play push come
on one more push it's your son
I'm all packed up thanks for everything
you and Mom have done for me I'm gonna
miss you dad
Baba you made the perfect home for me
growing up and I can only hope to create
the same for my family one last dance
Wow
hearts of stone it's almost as if you
aren't human but how will you react to
this message from your real life
father's son I a lot of you Wow it's a
photo finish we're gonna have to go to
replay let's take a look
Vaman cried last so it looks like
muhammad is the winner
[Applause]
[Music]
he didn't thank you to our CGI team who
mocked up the perfect photo of your
father's because of course they would
never say that Billy why don't you tell
us what Muhammad is one you'll be going
home in our grand prize a 2006 Toyota
Camry Kelly Blue Book value six thousand
two hundred ninety six dollars but we
got it for five that's a good deal
it always is on Bob
[Music]
you